le 19/20 continue voici le rappel des
titres charles pasqua et philippe seguin
son kill seul contre tous au rpr la
question est posée ce soir alors que
jacques chirac mobilisent pour le
mouvement gaulliste derrière lui notre
invité nicolas sarkozy député-maire
faire de neuilly qui doit beaucoup à
charles pasqua mais qui reste fidèle à
jacques chirac 500 millions de francs de
rallonge des locaux et les postes
supplémentaires lionel jospin a présenté
ce matin en conseil des ministres un
plan d'urgence pour l'université
objectif résoudre une situation devenue
explosive par les sureffectifs la
république bal des soviétiques de lutte
une amie veut son indépendance 15000
personnes l'ont réaffirmé aujourd'hui 24
heures avant la visite de michail
corvatsch mais tout de suite cette
information qui vient d'être confirmé le
pdg d'orange et rocks blessé gravement
et hier soir à la suite d'une prise
d'otages à la défense a été victime
d'une bavure policière enquête de la
police des polices confirmation du
procureur de la baie de la république
c'est bien un policier qui a tiré sur
olivier grouès le pdg de rucks et rocks
qui se trouve toujours dans un état très
grave
malgré dix heures d'opération caroline
site il est 19h30 le pdg de roxy rocks
olivier grouès et emmenées d'urgence
il a reçu une balle dans l'abdomen il
est dans un état très grave
peu avant lui daniel biel 45 ans et
emmenés par la police c'est lui qui a
pris en otage le pdg son adjoint et
trois assistantes c'est lui qui est le
premier suspect le premier accusé à bout
de nerfs ils auraient tiré mais ce soir
c'est le procureur de la république
qu'il affirme le pdg de ranxerox a été
blessé par un policier
la balle retiré de son abdomen a été
identifié comment expliquer une telle
bavure c'est entre 18h et 19h que tout
s'est passé lieux du drame la tour
bellini à la défense l'action se passe
entre deux étages au 19e le pdg de roncq
serock son adjoint et trois assistantes
prise en otage depuis 12h15 par un homme
daniel viel celui ci est un ancien
employé licencié il y a huit ans chômeur
divorce et plein de dettes il est venu
chercher une réhabilitation auprès de
celui qu'il rend responsable du désastre
de sa vie il est armé d'un fusil de
chasse au 18e étage juste en dessous la
police urbaine
pj de nanterre et le raid pendant plus
de six heures il négocié par téléphone
avec cet homme aux abois
vers 18 heures il accepte de relâcher
les trois femmes
le raid s'en va la faire semble se
dénouer mais tout dérape via l aurait
poussé ces otages vers l'escalier quatre
coups de feu et on retrouve le pdg est
tendue dans le couloir du 18e étage ce
serait le chauffeur du maître des
négociations qui auraient tiré il aurait
confondu le kidnappeur et le pdg il
n'aurait pas dû être armés pendant son
service ce soir il est entendu par
l'inspection générale des services la
crise ouverte au sein du rpr qualifié
d'agression par alain juppé l'épreuve de
force engagée par charles pasqua et
philippe seguin contre jacques chirac a
produit un effet inattendu le soutien
probable de l'ensemble du mouvement
gaulliste à son président elle reste
qu'à un mois des assises nationales du
fr le mouvement est fortement bouleversé
même déstabilisé par le schisme d'hier
cet après midi la réunion rpr udf s'est
déroulée dans un climat plutôt tendu
côté rpr pire sur explications et
réactions
eric piolle les sourires de circonstance
ne doivent pas faire illusion dans la
délégation rpr cet après midi on riait
jaune
edouard balladur faisait le tampon entre
charles pasqua d'un côté alain juppé
jacques chirac de l'autre
ambiance glaciale valéry giscard
d'estaing qui a risqué une plaisanterie
pour détendre l'atmosphère
il faut que la vie politique française
change at il dit les divisions au sein
du ps sont vraiment insupportable rires
dans l'assistance mais les responsables
rpr ont continué à se regarder en chiens
de faïence
ce matin alain juppé avait réuni toute
l'équipe nationale du rpr autour de lui
pour faire une démonstration de force
juppé et chirac vont se battre jusqu'au
bout s'ils perdent au soir du congrès le
11 février alain juppé en tirera les
conséquences et il quittera le rpr
s'il gagne en revanche il fera mordre la
poussière aux couples pasqua sega ans
les mandataires du temps à passer un
moment
franchi un certain nombre de limites
faut clarifier et à la limite je préfère
désormais clarifiée et peut-être moins
fort au départ qu'un rpr gras mais
et ce en ligne 60 cents détermination
commune à partir d'un corps alain juppé
va recevoir de main tendue les
parlementaires fidèle à jacques chirac
charles pasqua et philippe séguin eux
devront tenir une conférence de presse
pour expliquer leur déclaration de
guerre la lutte pour le contrôle du
parti est lancé c'est une lutte à mort
nicolas sarkozy vous avez 34 ans vous
êtes député et maire de neuilly vous
devez beaucoup à charles pasqua pourquoi
restez-vous fidèle à jacques chirac ou
c'est très simple
oui j'ai commencé la vie politique avec
charles pasqua oui je suis l'ami cha
pasqua mais je dis aussi simplement
aussi fortement contre charles pasqua
jacques chirac que j'ai choisie est mon
choix c'est jacques chirac avant
justement comme michèle barzach l'a
déclaré ce matin est ce que vous êtes
prêt vous est ce qu ont quitté leur
repère si charles pasqua on prend les
rênes non la question ne se pose pas
comme cela je suis prêt à me battre aux
côtés d'alain juppé jacques chirac pour
que la ligne politique est incarnée par
jacques chirac triomphe et je me plierai
naturellement aux règles de la
démocratie
nous verrons ce qu'il convient de faire
si nous triomphons pas mais nous ne
sommes pas dans ce cas de figure
aujourd'hui nous avons décidé de
mobiliser le mouvement autour de cet
objectif
jacques chirac est leader notre
mouvement nous souhaitons qu'il le reste
j'ajoute et permettez moi de vous le
dire que nous n'acceptons pas qu'on
remette en cause si peu que cela soit
l'union de l'opposition qui bien
nécessaire et si j'avais un commentaire
à faire un vrai commentaire sur ce qui
se passe je regrette car l'opposition
élu rpr n'avait pas besoin la facture de
10 millions supplémentaires au revoir
est restée assez violemment qu'est ce
qui vous dérange dans l'alliance seguin
pasqua pour vous souhaite une alliance
uniquement sous chirac
d'abord je me permets de vous dire je ne
réagis pas violemment vous ne posez une
question j'essaie d'y répondre
franchement il faut que dans le débat
politique on s'habitue à ce que les
responsables politiques prennent leurs
responsabilités disent ce qu'ils pensent
qu est ce qui me dérange
je vais essayer de vous y répondre là
aussi très clairement alliance contre
nature c'est une alliance contre nature
je voudrais prendre deux exemples qu'y
at il de commun entre charles pasqua qui
reconnaissait il ya quelques temps avoir
des valeurs communes avec le front
national et philippe seguin qui ne veut
même pas que l'on emploie le terme
d'identité nationale qui at il de commun
entre philippe seguin et c'est
parfaitement son droit qui souhaite
qu'il y ait une seule formation dans
l'opposition et charles pasqua qui
souhaitent militer c'est parfaitement
son droit également point rpr pur durée
solitaire ce n'est pas comme cela qu'on
leur en dressera la seconde pour la
république ce n'est pas pour cela et
comme cela que l'opposition redeviendra
victorieuse devant nicolas sarkozy vous
n'avez pas les mêmes valeurs et charles
pasqua
je vous dis tout simplement que moi je
me reconnais dans la ligne politique qui
est celle d'alain juppé jacques chirac
elle était c'est une pop mais les
valeurs les valeurs de charles pasqua
proches du front national alors c'est un
véritable question que vous posez nous
étions d'accord sur le fond nous
partageons un certain nombre de
convictions communes nous je n'ai pas
les mêmes valeurs que le front national
mais s'agissant des valeurs que
partagent charles pasqua et philippe
seguin
nous étions sur le point d'arriver à la
synthèse alain juppé avait fourni tous
les efforts possibles imaginables
j'appartiens au groupe qui a essayé de
chercher la synthèse nous n'y sommes pas
arrivés
et vous permettrez de vous dire que
l'alliance des contraires nous fait
penser que c'est plus une question de
forme et donc donne qu'une question de
fond dans le jeu le regrette pour notre
mouvement
moi je me suis engagé dans ce mouvement
parce que j'ai un idéal parce que j'y
crois et je considère aujourd'hui que le
mieux à même de leur présenter de
l'animé c'est chirac
dernière question vous avez 34 ans je
disais tout à l'heure le meilleur
candidat du rpr l'élection
présidentielle de 1995 ont donné un nom
c'est chirac c'est noir ou c'est pasqua
je vous donne un nom si jacques chirac
merci nicolas sarkozy d'avoir répondu à
nos questions à l'étranger malgré la
température polaire l'accueil promet
d'être chaud demain en lituanie pour
michael gorbatchev le numéro un
soviétique doit faire front aux
velléités d'indépendance proclamée par
le parti communiste de cette république
balte
un pari difficile pour mikhaïl
gorbatchev qui se trouvera demain face à
un pc particulièrement progressiste un
parti communiste qui va plus vite que
michailov est sauf
et pourtant trop lentement pour les
lituaniens prêts à descendre dans la rue
rémy gauzit de chagny la pérestroïka
serait-elle déjà dépassé dans les
républiques baltes en lituanie
communistes et nationalistes semble
vouloir le démontrer semaine après
semaine
aujourd'hui encore à la veille de la
visite de gorbatchev le mouvement
nationaliste lituanien a rassemblé près
de 20000 personnes dans le centre de
vilnius capitale de cet état de quatre
millions d'habitants
un seul slogan le retour à
l'indépendance dont jouissait la
lituanie avant l'annexion russe en 1940
cette nouvelle manifestation n'était pas
souhaitée par le parti communiste local
qui rivalise pourtant avec les
nationalistes pour symboliser l'esprit
d'indépendance soufflant sur la lituanie
c'est ainsi qu'il ya quinze jours les
communistes lituaniens après avoir
supprimé le rôle dirigeant du parti
coupet cette fois institutionnellement
le cordon ombilical avec moscou mais
l'histoire va décidément très vite et
lorsque michael gorbatchev tempête de
vent l'insolence des camarades
lituaniens il sait déjà qu'il doit la
supporter car derrière pousse des
nationalistes encore plus exigeant pour
le numéro un soviétique la rencontre
demain avec algirdas brazauskas le
secrétaire général du pc lituanien
relève de la haute stratégie politique
gorbatchev ne peut pas perdre la face à
moscou devant un comité central
traumatisé par l'embrasement des
poussées nationalistes mais il sait
qu'une majorité de lituaniens l'attend
comme l'homme du retour à l'indépendance
pure et simple du pays
michael gorbatchev semble avoir
jusqu'ici maîtriser les accélérations de
l'histoire dans les pays de l'est
l'histoire l'attend désormais dans ses
propres frontières en chine la levée de
l'état d'urgence ressemble fort à une
mesure de façade les télégrammes de
l'étranger jean-paul girouard
la loi martiale ap car c'est fini le
premier ministre li peng a annoncé à la
télévision
la levée de cette mesure d'exception
prises lors de la répression des
manifestations de juin dernier meeting
at il même réaffirmé sa foi dans un
communisme pur et dur qu'importe ce qui
peut se passer dans le monde at il dit
nous continueront de progresser sans
détour sur la voie socialiste
les pays de l'est devront tous se
diriger vers une économie de marché
décision attendue mais hautement
symbolique des participants au sommet du
comecon l'organisation économique de
l'urss et de ses alliés ils se sont
accordés sur la nécessité de changements
fondamentaux pour l'organisation
premier exemple le premier ministre
soviétique s'est prononcé pour un
remplacement du rouge bleu transférables
par une devise convertible
un nouveau mur sur le point de tomber
celui qui sépare les deux corées
le président sud coréen roh tew a
répondu favorablement à la proposition
d'une libre circulation entre les deux
pays
faites par son homologue du nord kim
tous les astronautes de la navette
columbia vont bien merci leur mission se
déroule à merveille cet après midi ils
ont argué et déployer un satellite de
communications militaires la soute est
désormais vide est prête à accueillir en
notre satellite scientifique celui là
que columbia va récupérer et ramenés à
terre en france des mesures d'urgence
pour la rentrée universitaire 1990 un
plan d'ensemble présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres par lionel jospin
pour faire face aux augmentations a
prévu du nombre de bacheliers candidats
comme il se doit aux études supérieures
500 millions de francs de rallonge
budgétaire des locaux et les postes
supplémentaires des mesures
exceptionnelles pour une situation qui
l'est tout autant
nick site lionel jospin le détail de ces
mesures
- éclaire tiers premièrement les
universités disposeront à la rentrée
prochaine de deux cent mille mètres
carrés de locaux supplémentaires soit en
location soit en construction
d'infrastructures légère mais de qualité
deuxièmement 400 postes d'enseignants
vont s'ajouter aux plus des 1400 emplois
nouveaux
déjà inscrits au budget 90 100 millions
de francs sont débloqués pour les heures
supplémentaires
enfin ce qu'on appelle les atos et les
personnels administratifs ouvriers et
techniciens les laissés-pour-compte de
l'enseignement supérieur bénéficieront
d'un plan de formation et d'équipement
en bureautique coût de ce plan d'urgence
500 millions de francs
le financement en sera précisée dans les
jours qui viennent
le budget de l'état n'y suffira pas
lancée il ya plus d'un an l'idée d'un
emprunt national refait surface
par ailleurs le ministre propose de
créer un partenariat avec les régions
lionel jospin annonce le dépôt lors de
la session parlementaire de printemps
d'une disposition législative qui
permettra à l'état de déléguer aux
collectivités territoriales la maîtrise
des bâtiments universitaires
alain carignon maire de grandes oeuvres
peut être impliqué dans une affaire de
fausses factures de l'ofii
hlm de sa ville une affaire de double
facturation donc qui va rebondir devant
la justice la requête du parquet était
devenue obligatoire après l'apparition
de nouveaux éléments dans le cadre de
l'enquêté ce soir cette requête concerne
donc alain carignon mais aussi
christiane d'ornano conseiller municipal
rpr de la ville de grenoble le point sur
l'enquêté
valérie bonnet le champion toutes
catégories de l'ouverture sur la
sellette l'image de transparence que
s'est efforcé de donner alain carignon
se noircit sérieusement détonateur la
sphère vincent rivier en enquêtant sur
les activités du promoteur isérois la
brigade financière de la pj de grenoble
fait apparaître des anomalies dans la
gestion de l'opal l'office hlm de la
ville
première conséquence la démission de
christine d'ornano conseillère
municipale chargée des travaux
mais cette mesure est loin de tordre le
cou à la rumeur et aux faux bruit
profitant de cet imbroglio
politico-judiciaire les élus
d'opposition réclament une réunion
exceptionnelle du conseil municipal sur
les problèmes de logement et remettent
en cause l'ensemble de la gestion
carignon la ville de grenoble est mal
gérée c'est en tout cas mon avis et
c'est la vie d'un nombre croissant de
gens en tant que conseiller municipal
leader d'ee
et du socialiste de grenoble nous tenons
à ce que la vérité éclate
les représentants de la liste écologie
autogestion sont encore plus formels ils
accusent le maire rpr d'avoir mis en
place un système à deux niveaux en
surface le look la publicité et en
profondeur en souterrain pourrait-on
dire un tissu de connivence de
clientélisme et de marchés de gré à gré
passer dans des conditions qui échappe
en tous les cas nous conseillers
municipaux de la minorité alain carignon
qui s'est exprimé lors d'une conférence
de presse le 29 décembre dernier refuse
de s'épancher à nouveau devant la caméra
pour lui les sous-entendus politiques
sont par trop évident dans cette affaire
à paris l'explosion d'une conduite de
gaz a fait plusieurs blessés cet après
midi voici le tour de france de
l'actualité en bref préparer et
commentée par nathalie darrigrand
13 personnes blessées dont cinq
grièvement cet après midi à paris lors
d'une explosion dans un hôtel du 12e
arrondissement
les blessés sont pour la plupart des
ouvriers qui travaillaient dans le
bâtiment en réfection
la rupture d'une conduite de gaz est à
l'origine de l'accident
le conseil administratif du collège de
creil a choisi hier d'interdire tout
signe religieux politique visible ou
démonstratif à l'école le texte rappelle
par ailleurs aux élèves l'obligation
d'assiduité scolaire ça n'ira qui
refusent toujours d'enlever son foulard
cours risquent désormais une sanction
disciplinaire explosion cette nuit à
bastia les deux voitures de
l'administrateur des affaires maritimes
de la haute corse ont été pulvérisées
pour l'instant l'attentât n'a pas été
revendiqué
quand les héros sont fatigués on les met
dans des musées et un retour au bercail
pour le dernier mystère iv encore en
état de vol après 33 ans de loyaux
services dans l'armée ce supersonique a
retrouvé aujourd'hui à bordeaux les
usines dassault qui l'avait vu naître en
57 avant de refermer cette édition j'ai
encore le temps de vous présenter deux
ouvrages qui viennent de paraître tout
d'abord le dernier né des documents du
nouvel observateur consacré à berlin le
jour où le monde a changé des photos
inédites et des articles de fond et puis
le dico sport c'est le dictionnaire des
sports corps champions règlement
résultats statistiques
l'ouvragé très très volumineux est très
important mais qui plaira bien sûr à
tous les passionnés de sport dans
quelques minutes la météo complète de
florence klein et après florence à 20h35
véronique une opérette en trois actes
d'andré messager à 22h30 par dans soir 3
et à 22h55 excusez-moi océaniques avec
andré soulas qui vous aurait retrouvé
tout de même un soir pour présenter une
nouvelle édition de 19 ans n'oubliez pas
la météo de florence klein anticyclone à
reste sur l'ensemble du pays tout va
bien bonne soirée à tous et à demain
m
bon